might be
a fun exercise of saying like what are
the main positions and submissions
in the art of jiu jitsu you don't have
to be complete that's
a ridiculously i apologize for putting
you on the spot like this but
it might be a nice exercise to think
through it sure i mean i would just say
that they're
they're you have your arms bend in
various ways you have
keylock americana straight arm locks
kimura omoplata alma plata is a kim
morgan
plot that's just executed missions
there's like submissions breaking off
your arm in all kinds of ways but
ultimately the question is let's say you
were a terminator like a robot that i
which of course you are
going on it's like all right so we're
being completely little
but uh and i and i couldn't harm you
with any of these things would i still
use these positions the answer is yes
they they create leverage they create
control they create shapes that i can
affect and that can affect me
and they can be affected through other
forces and other objects or structures
like the ground or the wall i really
enjoy mixed martial arts because
there's another component rather than
just me and you and the floor there's me
you the floor and the wall and it's
another player in the game that doesn't
exist
uh in a grappling context with an uh in
a non-enclosed
you know i guess area of combat but um
you can strangle me or choke me um what
do you call it uh
without my arms being involved or you
can use one of my shoulders
to pin one side of my one carotid artery
off and you can enclose the other
you can turn my knee in the exact same
ways that you can turn my arm
straight this way and that way you can
add a rotation to that or it can be
directly linear against the joint
so i guess what i would say is the more
that i've been able to understand
jiu jitsu the more that i've been it's
given me an
a look into how we learn language where
rather than learning five bazillion
adjectives i go i understand what an
adjective is and of course we are all
read into
some degree of vocabulary i understand
what an
adverb does and i understand what an
adverb is i know what a noun is i know
what the component parts of a sentence
are i know what you know i guess a
clause a contraction any of these things
and it allows you to be interesting and
artistic
with your language to the extent that
you can but i can't like i can speak a
degree of spanish but i'm not even
slightly artistic in spanish i would be
something could be i speak like uh like
a child with a head injury
and anyway um your basic understanding
of the english language allows you to
then be a student of spanish
100 but i'm limited by my experience i'm
limited by my
understanding of techniques and i'm
limited unders by my understanding
almost like
let's say techniques are like these are
like vocabulary um
so even if i kind of sort of grasp the
sentence structure and the thought
process and the thought patterns
of of spanish which it's interesting
because just even though the orientation
and the organization of a language and
i've thought about this a great deal
you know the way that i perceive the
world is affected deeply by the language
that i learned
you know the again if i learned i have
no idea the chinese language structures
but i can only imagine that it would be
that it would affect it's like a
different lens we're all looking at the
same thing but i have i have a different
set of sunglasses on than you do
and that's that's very very interesting
i'll use the quran as an example
you know apparently it's it's
unbelievably poetic in in arabic
still neat and was interesting reading
in english but
i'm told by people that i trust that it
just one doesn't bear resemblance to the
other and i think that's a very
interesting thing that you may be able
to say the same thing but in
in a more in i guess in a different way
in a more artistic way that
that may not translate on a one-for-one
kind of fidelity
but um the more that we're able to
understand
about how the body works the more
examples of the body work in this way
the body working that way the body
working that way
the more that i'm able to eventually
become an artist but it has to be
studied as a science first and it does
start with technique collection
vocabulary collection the same way we
learn
in school where you remember how to say
quickly
17 different ways and let's say i speak
spanish
i'm only i only know three so you might
use
quickly you might use an adjective like
quickly in spanish but use one of the
many many options to describe that that
i don't understand now i sit there and
go like
wait what i can't be artistic i can't be
as organic with the language as i'd like
so i believe that jiu jitsu a lot of
times starts with
the acquisition of a lot of hey do this
this this drill this technique here's an
american americana to an arm lock arm
lock to a triangle
um but the problem with that is
oftentimes we get stuck in that phase
um and i people eventually become move
collectors or sequence collectors and i
noticed this when i'm trying to do
dvds or i guess like an instructional
series now or even teaching in class
i don't believe in that form of learning
anymore um not that it's not valuable
but i don't believe
i don't understand jujitsu on that level
anymore so what i'm trying to do is get
across the basic ideas to people and say
hey
you need to fill in the gaps with going
to class all the time you need to go hey
learn this move learn that technique
learn that technique because otherwise
i'm basically just throwing at you
like 75 different words that you could
use but that hasn't really taught you
how to
how to speak a language whereas if you
give me a language structure
you can fill in these pieces on your own
and then eventually speak organically
in lex form which will be ultimately
unique to you because otherwise you just
end up being
a weird facsimile of whatever it is that
i'm doing
for mostly the worst i'd say but uh
yeah that's what people i mean people
comment like is this especially people
haven't listened to me before uh is this
guy drunk or high
does he does mit really allow
slow people to uh to be like what
is it like what's what's wrong with him
is he getting sleep are you okay
and does he need help so that that's
similar with my jiu jitsu it's like this
is this guy is this guy
really whatever rank i was throughout
i i remember just like is this guy
really this rank
i just have a very kind of certain way
of sitting and being slow and
lazy looking that that was ultimately
the language that i had to discover and
it was uh it was yeah it was a very
liberating
moment i think of
probably a few years of getting my ass
kicked
especially with open guard and butterfly
to where you really allow yourself to
take in the entirety of the language and
realize that um
that i'm not i'm different i'm a unique
i'm i'm unique and like i have a very uh
i have a language i have a set of
techniques a way i
move my body that needs that i'm the one
to discover like it's
you can only you can learn specific
techniques and so on but you really
have to understand your own body that's
the beautiful thing about
jiu jitsu like you said is like the the
connection about
your philosophy your view of the world
with the physical
and like connecting those two things how
you perceive the world
how you interpret ideas of the world
about
exhaustion about force about
effortlessness like what it really means
to relax all these kinds of loose
concepts
and then actually teach your body to
like
do those things and like you know
and be able to apply force and spurts to
be able to relax in spirits and like
figure all that stuff out
for my for your my individual body but
it's
as you mentioned that's i couldn't agree
with you more it's a discovery process
and no one can cheat that process
which is at the same time it's almost
like imagine i want to start writing
books in second grade unless
maybe i'm like staggeringly brilliant i
wish i can only conceptualize someone
being able to do that but
maybe a mozart of the english language
where you're out there doing it
but for most of us we don't have enough
knowledge enough information enough
experience to be able to
be to express ourselves so we have to
basically
input repeat which is important but it's
the process as you say of going through
that of getting your ass kicked
just like well that didn't work well
that didn't work that felt right but i
don't know nobody else does that i guess
i don't believe in that
versus eventually going i don't know
i'll just try going my own way and see
what happens and now i'll get yelled at
and people won't like me and if it works
they'll say i got lucky and if it
doesn't work they'll say i was dumb
but uh which one maybe all is right but
basically uh
you know going through that iterative
process that allows you to eventually
find your self-expression and find your
voice so that you
you fight the same way that you speak
the same way that you write the same way
that you think in a way that
that is uniquely you that will also
ultimately allow you
to understand other people being
uniquely them because even if you can
only conceptualize and i think about
this a lot for
society stuff where i go well this is
how i feel about this but
am i objectively right maybe about a
couple things but that's a small box
that i have to be very very careful
about what i think is objective
and versus what's not and i have to be
open to the possibility that all the
things that i think are
objectively correct may or may not be
and that should allow me to have some
degree of compassion or consideration
for other people both in their martial
arts journey and in their
in their journey you know as people as
human beings because i understand
that they're on a it's a we're all on a
path right it's all a
again an iterative process of eventual
self-expression but i think that's one
of the things that we
see having trouble when we see tribalism
which i mean
racism expression of that political
affiliation expression of that
all of these things that can go in
really uncomfortable directions people
are looking for
hey where do i plant my feet over here
where's where's the thing that i know is
right and that we can all agree on the
following
and i think that we see that in martial
arts we're like oh i do this style why
do that style i do that stuff we're like
hey man we're all
just pushing forward in a certain
direction here trying to do our best and
i understand why you feel the way you do
i may have felt like that at one point
too
but uh you know what i'm just trying to
learn and understand
versus i've already acquired enough
knowledge let me cross my arms and start
to
to look who's [ __ ] up around here
yeah and and i think that uh
that's an it's an interesting trap that
i think is very human trapped to fall
into but it definitely happens early on
it's something it's a joke in the
jujitsu world right like on the blue
belt that knows everything well
initially it's like what i know nothing
and i
at least think i know nothing then i'd
learn a little bit and i think it's a
lot bit
and then you know the more you learn the
more you go like i don't even know what
i'm doing
yeah that's exactly right
you